MALE SPEAKER: I want to welcome
our guest, Gary Catona, who's
going to be talking
about voice building.
He has been the voice builder
to the stars in the past.
And we're going to talk about
voice building to the world,
about all the different
ramifications for what
that may mean to anybody.
You don't have to be
a singer, necessarily,
to appreciate
building your voice
and what it can do for you.
Now, Gary's thinking about doing
this on a global scale, which
at Google, is
pretty interesting.
That's thinking really big.
That's a 10x thinking
and something
that we can truly relate
to and appreciate.
Gary has worked with some
of the greatest singers
and entertainers of our time.
Really amazing if
you've had a chance
to look through the full list.
And we're going to
chat about some of them
today, his
experiences with them,
what he's learned over
the past two decades,
and some of the techniques.
Gary has a master in philosophy
from Penn State University,
and this directly impacted how
he goes about his tradecraft
and how hes approaches
the problem.
So we're going to
discuss how philosophy
comes into voice building.
So from Whitney Houston
to Andrea Bocelli
to Tony Bennett to Steven
Tyler to even Muhammad Ali,
this is just a partial list.
The list goes on and on and on.
So without further ado,
I want to introduce Gary.
And Gary's going to give
us a little bit more
about his background and show
you a short introductory video.
So thank you, Gary.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY CATONA: Thanks for coming.
I appreciate it.
It's wonderful to be here and
to be around so many eager minds
who are always willing and able
and interested in exploring
new ideas.
My story has been
an interesting one.
I began with a simple
passion to become a singer
when I was growing
up in Philadelphia,
Italian-American family, with
Frank Sinatra and the Beatles
playing both at the same house.
And I just developed this
passion to become a singer,
and it started me on the quest
to discover what a great-- what
a beautiful voice is.
And during that process,
it was a very bumpy road
because I had to
unlearn much of what
I was taught by my teachers.
And in the final
analysis, I ended up
putting together a process that
I call voice building that I've
been using now for
the past 20 years
or so that has made
a major impact on how
people deal with their voices.
And my goal at this point
is to take my process
and to create as many
beautiful voices as possible
all over the world.
So how many people
here are singers?
And how many have studied voice?
And how many people
here use their voices
in their profession?
Everybody, right?
Are you aware of
the major impact
that the quality of your
voice has on your work?
We know that we have
a tremendous response
to the sound of a
person's voice--
not just what you're saying,
but the actual quality
of your voice can sometimes
make the difference
between success and failure.
This is part of
the message that I
want to pass on-- that I have
been passing on for some time.
MALE SPEAKER: And
[INAUDIBLE] what
is your vision for your work?
GARY CATONA: The more
I teach, the more I
realize how important
the voice is.
Think about it.
We all speak.
We all love music.
We all love singers.
Yet it's the one field where
we don't think enough about.
We think working out and the
proper nutrition and so on.
But very few of us really think
very much about our voice.
And think about how
crucial your voices are.
I mean, look what
we're doing right now.
We're talking, communicating.
And your voice is interesting.
The voice is almost a
mystical aspect of who we are.
Think about it for a second.
In the actual quality
of your voice, you live.
Your identity, your personality,
your emotions, your moods,
your feelings, all
within sound waves.
But how is that possible?
How could mere
sound waves capture
the essence of who you are?
So whenever you're
speaking, you're
literally transmitting
who you are in your voice.
So it stands to
reason that you should
try to have the best
voice you can possibly
have to express who
you are, whether it's
in a personal relationship
or in your profession.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
and obviously,
to Googlers,
elaborating on voice,
that could be a unique way
of doing things in the future
to create better
user experiences.
And so we need to think
deeply about voice
and all its technical
implications as well.
GARY CATONA: And I'm going to
show you a quick little video
that we put together
that kind of gives you
a summation of my career.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - WHITNEY HOUSTON,
"I WILL ALWAYS LOVE YOU"]
-I understand you met
Whitney Houston back in 2004
after being introduced
by Stevie Wonder
and began working with her.
What kind of a shape was
her voice in back then?
-When I went to
see her in Atlanta,
her voice was in
horrible condition.
Her speaking voice and her
singing voice were both hoarse.
She had about one audible
tone in her lower register.
I was horrified.
I had this image of her
being a young, beautiful lady
with this incredible voice.
And here she is,
sitting in front of me,
with no voice whatsoever.
I got her voice
back at probably 75%
by the time she did her record.
[MUSIC_-_ANDREA_BOCELLI]
-Actually, Gary's system
is the only system
that I really tried before.
Most of the time, I wasn't
interested in trying
any of the other systems.
And I did only two to
two and a half weeks
of this voice building.
That is almost like a miracle
because I would always
give out.
And I did more
singing on that tour
than I had ever done before.
-I think I owe the range
that I have in my voice now
and the fact that I can sing
for long periods of time
with strength and no
laryngitis to Gary.
It's been remarkable for me.
-I noticed that my voice
was getting louder,
it seemed to project
louder, and that I
was able to go
deeper in tone than I
used to be able to and higher.
So it affected my highs,
my mids, and my lows.
-Taking care of business.
-You always have a lot of
stuff to do in the morning?
-Not too much.
-They tell me you're
an actor, Muhammad Ali.
Are you really an actor?
-Yes.
I've been acting.
I've deceived the world.
I actually made the people
think that I couldn't talk.
-Hello.
This is Mike Wilmington.
I'm talking into a tape recorder
on Wednesday, September 17,
or thereabouts.
My voice sounds this way
because of a condition
which has been prescribed
by several doctors
as spastic dysphonia.
This is Mike Wilmington.
I've had my voice back
now for about two years,
thanks to Gary Catona and his
voice building techniques.
-When cancer struck "Odd
Couple" star Jack Klugman,
doctors were forced to remove
one of his vocal cords.
He lost his voice and
nearly lost his career.
Well now, we have
the man who helped
the star get his voice back
in our "Entertainment Tonight"
cover story.
-I think I hear a sound.
-Well, it's a matter of
taking these muscles that
are by nature very tough
and applying exercise
to make them overwork.
And the result is very
dramatic, and it's very fast.
-It was like finding gold to me.
I love it.
And I'm able to work.
Look at that.
I have the power.
I can express emotion.
And it's all because of him.
-His other students have
ranged from Liza Minnelli
and the lead singer
of Limp Bizkit
to Tony Bennett and operatic
tenor Andrea Bocelli.
-To have somebody like that
put his voice in your hands
and say, make it better,
was quite a delight for me.
-Catona has also worked
with Lisa Marie Presley
and Grammy-winning singer Seal.
-Welcome to "Talk of Asia."
I'm Lorraine Hahn.
And joining me, international
superstar Liza Minnelli
andher voice coach, Gary Catona.
-Because I would have said
if I was sitting here alone,
there's a man called Gary
Catona who I trust with my life.
I'm chasing him.
I follow--
-Not romantically, I presume.
-No.
-And I want her to chase me.
So I came here.
I knew that's how
it would happen.
-No, I knew Gary had
to be here working,
and I have to take my
lessons because I just
had an operation on my throat,
and I couldn't speak at all,
let alone sing.
And I knew the only
person that could
make me sing the way I wanted
to, with God's gift, which
is brand new vocal cords,
would be Gary Catona.
That I could get-- I'll just
show you, on the bottom,
I'll do [RASPY SINGING].
That's the bottom.
So if you go, [RASPY_SINGING]
I'm just a girl who
can't-- now.
Do something.
Help me.
[SINGING] I'm just a
girl who can't say no.
You know, it's all there.
-Fascinating.
-I love talking
about what works.
Because it's great
to talk about what if
and what could
be, but damn, when
you find something that works--
-And so joining us now is
voice builder Gary Catona.
-The first point
I want to make is,
think of the voice in
terms of being a muscle.
So what do you do with muscles?
-You treat it like an athlete.
-That's right.
So my concept is
you use your voice
in an exercise routine that
stresses out the vocal muscles.
As an example, if I do
this-- [SINGING WITH VIBRATO]
[MUSIC - WHITNEY HOUSTON,
"I WILL ALWAYS LOVE YOU"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: Well, that's
quite impressive, Gary.
GARY CATONA: You see
the variety of people
that I work with,
not just for singers,
but people who have
vocal problems,
even medical conditions.
MALE SPEAKER: Now
your approach to it,
coming with a philosophy
degree and having been a singer
yourself, you took a
fundamentally different
approach than many
folks in your field did.
So you might be seen
somewhat as a disruptor.
GARY CATONA: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: So how did the
quote, "current community"
of vocal building
and vocal analysis,
were they receptive
to your work at first,
or did it take a while to
basically win people over?
How did you go about that?
GARY CATONA: It's like
whenever you introduce
something new that conflicts
with the prevailing wisdom,
you always get a push back.
And in my case, it
was very severe.
What I do in terms
of my technique
is the complete opposite of
what everybody else teaches,
for the most part.
For example, when
you study voice,
you're oftentimes taught
to sing from the diaphragm
and to relax your throat and
sing the nasal passages, where
for me, it's the opposite.
You spend all your
time in the throat
and ignore the
diaphragm altogether.
And these the kinds of ideas
that antagonize people.
And even when I had
evidence that what I did
worked, because I had some
really, really nice results,
even with people with
medical conditions,
I still was considered
a person non grata.
MALE SPEAKER: So
often when you're
this person in any field
or industry, someone
discovers you or
helps the breakthrough
or the aha moment that actually
says, I believe in this person,
and I believe in
what they're doing,
and I've seen
fundamental results.
Who is the person that quote,
"discovered" you, if you will?
GARY CATONA: You know,
I had those moments.
It's just remarkable to
think that within the course
of a year and a half, I had
four people who discovered me,
so to speak.
Any one of whom would have done
it, but I had four at once.
And probably the most profound
one was Shirley MacLaine.
She was about to go on
tour with Frank Sinatra.
And she wasn't a singer, really.
And she heard about me
through another student.
And out of the clear blue sky,
I got a phone call one day.
I'm living in this one-bedroom
apartment in Hollywood,
hardly making any income
whatsoever, and just wondering
what I'm going to do next.
Next thing I know, the phone
rings, it's Shirley MacLaine.
And she said to me, what
are you doing in one hour?
I said, let me see here.
Uh, I'm free.
She says, I'll be right over.
She drove from Malibu to
my place in Hollywood,
and I started
giving her a lesson.
And within 10 minutes
after giving her a lesson,
she said, you're
going on tour with me.
And from her came Tony Bennett,
Liza Minnelli, Andy Williams.
And then I went on tour
with her and Sinatra,
and that was a whole
'nother story altogether.
MALE SPEAKER: So at the
beginning of the video,
we heard a beautiful,
familiar voice.
What was it like working
with Whitney Houston?
GARY CATONA: Boy.
Imagine working with one the
greatest voices of all time.
And what's interesting
psychologically
is when you teach somebody
that you admired as a fan.
Think about that.
Imagine somebody that you--
whether it's in sports
or whatever.
And before you know it, the
person is sitting before you
and saying, show
me how to do this.
One of the greatest
voices of all time.
She is the embodiment of--
she has so many vocal virtues,
it's hard to discuss them,
besides her beautiful tone,
her strong voice, her amazing
range, her inherent musicality.
It was a wonderful experience.
And she responded very,
very, very quickly
to my vocal exercises.
MALE SPEAKER: Now
when great singers
like Andrea Bocelli, Tony
Bennett, Steven Tyler--
one of my all-time favorites--
they're putting their trust
in you with their
voices, their livelihood.
That's an immense
responsibility.
What's that like?
The burden, there's
a certain burden
and a certain weight
that goes with that.
GARY CATONA: Well,
it's interesting.
You have to-- for
people with those kind
of large personalities,
your first goal
is to convince that person that
you know what you're doing.
Because they're used to telling
everybody else what to do.
So here you are, standing
in front of a superstar,
and you have to tell
that person what to do,
and that person has to
listen without compromise.
Because if the person
doesn't listen,
the results are not
there, and then you fail.
So one of my first
goals is to convince
the person what I do is real.
And the way I do that is
demonstrate with my own voice
different kinds of
exercises, and I
have a pretty strong voice.
And once they heard
my voice, then they're
open, more available
to being taught.
And luckily, my
results are fast,
so when I began
to work with them,
they heard the results in
their voices very quickly.
And before you know it,
they're devoted students.
MALE SPEAKER: Now working with
that diverse group of singers
and entertainers and other
notable public figures, what
was the common thread,
the common denominator,
or common note, if you would,
that you saw between them?
Was there such an element
that you could identify?
GARY CATONA: Yeah, I
think the people that
are really successful
in this field,
they have a lot of
personality characteristics
that are in common, one
of which is that they have
a determination
to be successful,
and nothing will stop them,
and they have no other choice.
When I have a student that
says to me, if I don't make it
as a singer, I'll
go to law school--
when I hear that, I normally
say, please go to law school.
Because you have to
have almost an obsession
to be this kind of person.
Because think about it.
It's a desire to have the
whole world look at you
and say, look how
wonderful you are.
Look how great you are.
And if you're a real artist,
if you have real talent,
you have a major
impact on the world.
That's what being a performer
can do and being a singer
can do.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Well, I want to transition
here to your vision
that you mention upfront from
voice builder to the stars
to the voice builder
of the world.
So let's talk about
reaching beyond singers.
You've worked with a
wide range of people.
One of the things
that I was intrigued,
when I was reading
about your bio,
was that you helped
Muhammad Ali and Jack
Klugman, who were suffering
from vocal disorders.
Can you tell us a
little bit how you
went beyond singing
and entertainers
into helping people
that may have
a medical issue or
other injury type issue?
GARY CATONA: What's
interesting is
that my initial interest
in developing my system
was to work with singers,
but my first successes
were with people with
vocal difficulties.
And I became very well known
throughout the country,
in fact, the world,
by returning people
with damaged speaking voices.
And Muhammad Ali
was one of them.
He had Parkinson's
syndrome, which
causes the voice, the
slur, and the voice
to get very, very weak.
And by doing the exercises,
his voice got stronger.
And then you saw Jack
Klugman in the video.
He had throat cancer.
He had his throat irradiated.
And they took off one
vocal cord and replaced it
with a prosthetic.
So when I got his
voice, he had nothing.
So for me, I wasn't
really sure whether I
could help the guy out,
to be honest with you.
But during the course
of a few months,
his voice returned
very effectively.
MALE SPEAKER: And there
was another person
you worked with, a jazz
guitarist, Larry Carlton.
GARY CATONA: Larry Carlton.
MALE SPEAKER: Who basically
suffered a severe gunshot
wound to the throat?
GARY CATONA: That's correct.
MALE SPEAKER: And if
I recall, basically
was left with one
functioning vocal cord,
and the other one was paralyzed.
How do you work with
somebody like that
on an injury that's
that in depth?
GARY CATONA: It's
quite a challenge.
Because when you
sing or speak, you
need to close the
glottis in the throat.
That causes the
cords to vibrate.
Right?
Everybody knows that who
understands music and singing.
What happens if
one is paralyzed?
How do you have-- because
when one's paralyzed,
that means when the person
speaks, rather than doing this,
that happens, and
all the air escapes.
That was my challenge.
So my whole process is
based upon exercise.
Now, how do you exercise
a voice with only one cord
that's moving?
Well, this is how I did it,
through experimentation.
Here's what I found.
I would ask Larry
to change pitch.
And this was his
voice, basically.
[RASPING] That was his voice.
That's the voice I
had to deal with.
So here's what I noticed.
When I had him change
pitch, on certain pitches,
the breath would
increase in pitch.
I'd hear this-- [BREATH
CHANGING IN PITCH].
That told me that there
was some kind of movement
in the vocal mechanism
that caused the breath
pitch to rise.
So what I did is I
stayed on that pitch,
and slowly but surely, I
heard this-- [RASPING].
Before I know it, the
voice began coming back,
and the whole voice returned.
What happened was
the one functioning
vocal fold overcompensated
for the one that
was paralyzed and,
past the midline,
had made contact with the
one that wasn't moving.
So he had the strongest
vocal cord in the world.
MALE SPEAKER: So that raises
an interesting point, again,
this vision of voice
builder to the world.
Can anyone learn your technique?
Can it be somebody that's a
public speaker at Toastmasters?
Could it be a young child?
Is there a certain age
that you would or would not
teach this particular
technique, or does it basically
apply to anybody?
GARY CATONA: Anybody
could use this process.
I use the analogy of
being like a sport,
because singing and using
your voice is athletic,
and it's based upon the use of
muscles in the vocal mechanism.
So if you have the
proper kind of exercises,
you can develop your voice.
Now, everybody, no matter
how tone deaf some of you
might think you are, all of
you have musical ability.
You recognize rhythms,
and you hear patterns,
and you remember music,
and you like music.
So music is a part of our DNA.
That's how we're hard-wired.
We love music.
The problem is transferring
the experience of music
to the physical
process of singing.
And what that requires
is the vocal mechanism,
which is made of
muscles, to correspond
to when you're
hearing something.
So if I hear [HUMMING],
I have a [HUMMING].
That means what I'm
hearing and what
I'm producing are the same note.
When you build your
voice, what you're doing
is you're increasing the
ability of the vocal muscles
to respond to what
you're hearing.
So you develop what I call
ear-throat coordination.
And that's why virtually anybody
who undergoes this process
could develop a singing voice.
MALE SPEAKER: So when
you say the process,
how do you see, beyond the
interaction we had just there,
but how do you see
technology playing
an enabling force for you
to achieve your vision?
How are you going to
reach out to the world
and teach the world these
types of techniques?
How do you see technology
playing a part?
GARY CATONA:
Technology is crucial.
For example, in my case, I
have a voice building app
that people use, that's
called Voice Builder, that
actually builds people's voices.
It's not as good as being
in front of a live teacher,
but it works very, very well.
And with the wonder
of the internet,
I teach through Skype,
sometimes, for example.
And technology
itself, we're going
to start a voice
building academy, which
will be a one on one interactive
school where we're teaching
a number of, maybe, 100 people
at once to undergo the voice
building process.
So technology is
crucial in realizing
what I see my goal,
my vision to be.
MALE SPEAKER: And this can
be a mobile application.
People can do it
wherever they're at,
whatever platform they
may be on in the future.
GARY CATONA: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Now, I know you used
Hangouts with my son.
And it was great to see
that interaction technology
to bring together you,
in a remote place,
teaching my son voice
building exercises,
and the clarity with which you
can hear his pitch and voice
was extraordinary.
So it had a--
GARY CATONA: I
worked with his son,
who has a vocal difficulty.
And over the course
of a few minutes,
his voice began returning and
had a very strong response
to it.
MALE SPEAKER: You couldn't
see us, but off the camera--
he didn't see us-- there was
tears in his parents' eyes.
That's the first time we heard
his voice come out like that.
Being that you approached
it from a different angle,
you wrote a book called
"Revolution in Singing."
What is that book all about?
When you say revolution,
what do you mean by that.?
GARY CATONA: Well,
what I did was
I-- the book was about
the history of singing
in general, how,
where it originated,
some salient singers
throughout history that
have made a profound impact,
like Caruso and Frank Sinatra
and Paul McCartney and all
of these various singers
that have made such an
impact on our culture.
But also, I go through the
principles of great singing.
I talk about how I
developed my process,
and I try to overcome-- there
are a number of misconceptions
about the voice
that are preventing
many, many singers
that are naturally
talented from becoming great.
There are people
in this room that
would have great voices if
you underwent this process,
and if you would let
go the old concepts.
For example, if you're told
that you're stuck with the voice
you're born with-- you're told
this, and that's not true.
Because the voice is
composed of muscles,
you literally can
build your voice.
The voice that you speak with
is not your natural voice.
It's the voice that has
evolved over time based
upon your childhood experiences
and your psychological
characteristics and whether
or not you're a singer.
So the voice that you
have is an adapted sound,
which means you
can take that sound
and build it with
the proper exercises.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, when
went in this study field,
you actually went back to
an historical perspective,
if I recall, and actually looked
at one of the greatest opera
singers of all time,
sort of as a mentor.
GARY CATONA: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: And looking
at some of the techniques
that he did at the
turn of the century.
Can you elaborate, one,
who he was and two,
what you learned from looking
at that historical perspective?
GARY CATONA: The greatest opera
singer probably of all time
was this gentleman
named Enrico Caruso, who
was an Italian tenor,
who died in 1921.
He wrote a book called
"The Art of Singing."
In it, he talked about using his
throat muscles to create sounds
and singing from the
back of the throat.
Now, most of you don't
really understand
what that might mean.
But if you study
voice today, you're
told to sing out of
your throat and to sing
to your nasal cap, which
is called the mask.
But what they teach
today is the opposite
of what Caruso teaches, which is
the greatest voice of all time.
So how did that ever happen?
So that was a light for me.
When I read-- I just said,
this is what Caruso says.
We have to take him seriously.
When he says, sing from
the back of the throat,
how can you sing from
the back of the throat
and sing in the
front-- in the mask?
How do you do that
at the same time?
It's not physically possible.
Somebody has to be right,
and someone has to be wrong.
Caruso was right.
MALE SPEAKER: So you've often
talked about that he was right,
but there's a field
of isokinetics.
Can you tell the audience
what that's all about
and how you think it directly
applies to your philosophy
and approach to voice building?
GARY CATONA: When I went through
the process of developing
my voice building
system, I discovered
a kind of exercise program
that's called isokinetics.
And what I discovered
is a way of applying
that form of exercise
to the vocal muscles.
And I can tell you what
it is very quickly.
It means taking
muscles through motion
while keeping the
movement constant,
while keeping the pressure
maximized at the same time.
That concept builds muscles.
So I discovered a
way of applying that
to vocal exercises
that results in
very strong, very
rapid vocal growth.
MALE SPEAKER: So we'd
like to take a moment
to open it up to the
audience for questions.
Please, before you ask
a question, make sure
you have the mic
in hand and it's
turned on, so that
way, everybody can
hear your question and
also for later playback.
So if we can have a volunteer.
AUDIENCE: My uncle has
spasmodic dysphonia.
And I was wondering, I know--
I guess he could fly out
and book a session with you, but
does your app help with that?
Or is there some sort of like
Hangout session you can do
or something like that
where you can work with him?
GARY CATONA: The guy with the
vocal condition on the video
had spasmodic dysphonia.
Yes, the app will help the
person, without a doubt.
AUDIENCE: And you're also
available for like Hangout kind
of bookings or things like that?
GARY CATONA: Well, probably.
Just go to my website,
which is garycatona.com,
and all of my
information is on there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARY CATONA: You're welcome.
MALE SPEAKER: Could
bring a whole new meaning
to a Helpout, a voice
building Helpout.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually
a voiceover artist,
and I'm actually on my way to
a recording just after this,
so I'm hoping I can come
away with something of value.
As vocal actors, taking and
doing things like e-books
and long term reading, a
couple of hours at a stint,
I find that very
difficult, and I
find that my pitch changes as
I go through the recording,
so that by the time I'm at
the end of the recording,
you can actually
go back and listen.
GARY CATONA: That's right.
AUDIENCE: What are some of the
controls and exercises that
could be done to stabilize?
GARY CATONA: The
problem is what's
happening is your larynx
is rising over time,
which makes your voice rise.
So the way you deal with that
is doing certain exercises which
drop your larynx.
And I'll show you one right now.
Put your finger on
your Adam's apple.
Everybody do it.
Everybody go ooh.
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
GARY CATONA: Where does
the Adam's apple go?
AUDIENCE: Down.
GARY CATONA: Down.
So watch this exercise.
[SINGING] Oooooooh.
See it?
AUDIENCE: And run
through that cycle--
GARY CATONA: Run
through that cycle.
Do it like three or four notes,
up and back, very, very slowly,
full voice.
And it'll help you a great deal.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARY CATONA: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: --for the
interesting presentation.
GARY CATONA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What would you say is
the most common mistake people
make with their voice, that
someone off the street,
when they talk to
you, you say, ah,
you're doing something wrong.
What would you say is
the most common mistake?
GARY CATONA: For
singers in particular?
AUDIENCE: For
whatever the-- yeah.
GARY CATONA: Well, the
mistake-- basically
first they'll have certain
misconceptions about the voice,
one of which I spoke about.
The fact that the voice is
fragile is a misconception.
The voice is very tough.
It's able to endure
a lot of stress.
If you're a singer, the number
one mistake I see with singers,
they sing in the wrong key.
People have an obsession
with high notes
to the point of causing the
larynx to-- whenever you cause
the larynx to rise
unnaturally, over time,
the voice begins
collapsing and develops
all these vocal conditions that
you probably have heard about.
Did you know that the voice
matures at the age of 35 to 40,
45?
Yet in the world, most people in
the rock business, for example,
by that time, their
voices are gone.
The very moment when their
voices should be the best,
they lose it because they're
screaming out these notes
and not preparing themselves
like athletes the way
that they should.
You got it.
MALE SPEAKER: So there's
still an opportunity for me
to hit the rock tour at my age?
GARY CATONA: Can you move?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Gary.
GARY CATONA: Hello, love.
AUDIENCE: So who is the
best singer in the Beatles?
Who's your favorite
singer in the Beatles?
Is it really Ringo?
GARY CATONA: Well,
let me explain.
A singer is an
interesting thing.
There are three aspects
of singing, the voice,
the vocalist, and the singer.
Whenever-- anybody you want
to consider as a singer,
think about the
three components.
The vocalist is being able
to sing on pitch, having
the right technique, and so on.
The voice is what's
distinctive about your voice.
As soon as you hear
that voice, you know it.
Frank Sinatra, Barbara
Streisand, Stevie Wonder.
There are people that
are great vocalists,
but they don't have
the good voices
because you don't
recognize who they are.
They make great background
singers or jingle singers,
but because they
lack the voice, they
have a problem making it
as an individual artist.
And then there's the singer.
The singer is being
able to make people
feel what you're singing about.
Somebody could have a bad voice,
not being a very good vocalist,
but they're very good singers.
Did I mention Bob Dylan?
But you see what
I'm trying to say?
So whenever you
evaluate a singer,
think about those
three questions.
How is the person as a vocalist,
as a singer, and as a voice?
So the answer to
your question, who
do you think the best singer is?
AUDIENCE: I always liked Paul.
GARY CATONA: Do you think
Paul's the best singer?
Now think about
what I just said.
Is he the one-- does he make
you feel the most or not?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'd choose Paul.
GARY CATONA: I'd have to
go with Lennon, personally.
AUDIENCE: So I've taken
some voice classes, too,
and one of the things that
was really fascinating
is if you take guitar lessons,
if you screw something up,
people can see it.
They say, OK, change your
position, do this, do this.
It's a much easier
way of teaching
because you see what's wrong.
But with voice, you
really don't see
a lot of what's happening in the
throat, so you have to listen,
and you have to interpret what
probably this guy's doing wrong
and how to-- like my vocal
teacher used to say, OK,
imagine there's like
a ping pong ball
at the back of your
throat, whatever.
GARY CATONA: So horrible.
AUDIENCE: Right?
So then, clearly, you're
more successful than a lot
of ther coaches.
So what makes you
special in that way?
Because it seems like there's
an art to it, in a sense.
You kind of have to feel it
because you don't see it.
GARY CATONA: Well,
the whole problem
with the field of teaching,
based upon the funnel effect
of human nature, is that
the voice is invisible.
You can't see it.
You can't touch it.
You can't smell it.
You can't taste it.
You can barely feel it.
So it happens on the inside.
So there's almost like a
magical component to it.
A person stands there
and opens up his voice,
and all the sudden, this
amazing voice comes out.
Where is it coming from?
So it stands to
reason that people
that are great singers
by nature don't really
know how they do what they do.
It's one of the downsides
of being gifted at anything.
If you're a gifted runner
or a gifted tennis player,
you don't know
why you're gifted.
You just have it.
And yet those are the very
people that end up teaching.
Think about that for a second.
That answers a lot of questions.
How can it be that the field
of singing is in such disarray?
because the people that have
the responsibility of passing
on the art form have no idea
what they're talking about.
They just do it by nature, and
they have to make a living,
so why not teach?
So you have to base upon
the vocal study on science.
And in my case, it's the science
of how the vocal muscles work.
What I've done is I've aligned
my exercises specifically
with how the local mechanism
works on a biochemical level.
And that's the only way
you should teach voice.
AUDIENCE: Your exercises, do
they help in public speaking,
in the sense that your
range of tonality,
is that just a learned
habit, or is there really
something else to it?
GARY CATONA: I'm sorry, I
didn't hear the question.
AUDIENCE: In public
speaking, I tend
to have a noticeably
smaller range of tones.
So could your exercises help
in that kind of [INAUDIBLE],
or is it just a learned habit?
GARY CATONA: Are you
talking about pitch range?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GARY CATONA: Your
pitch, when you
change pitch, your vocal cords
change length like a string.
The higher you go, the
longer the cords become.
What controls that
movement are muscles.
So again, it stands to
reason that if you exercise
those muscles, what
happens to that range?
[SINGING WITH RISING PITCH]
It goes up.
So the proper exercise will
definitely increase and improve
your pitch ability.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds like a
common theme is approaching it
as a muscle.
GARY CATONA: Absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: And most
people, through the years,
have experienced
some form of atrophy,
in that they haven't
exercised that range,
and it becomes smaller as you
get older just because you
don't--
GARY CATONA: Singing is an
art form, but the basis of it
is science.
And there are two different
dimensions that people confuse.
They try to make the teaching of
singing into too much of an art
form and not enough
of a science.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So if I feel as though
the sound's coming
from inside my head,
it doesn't mean
you teach that because that's
physiologically impossible.
It means you teach it
properly, and then you
deal with the artistic
dimension in a different way.
But most teachers don't
understand that distinction.
So again, think
of it as a sport.
When you sing, you're an artist.
But as a student,
you're a voice builder.
AUDIENCE: I talk with a
very low tone of voice,
but I would like to make it
higher because I keep getting
lower and lower and lower,
and I don't really like it.
GARY CATONA: Well,
I like your voice.
And I think you should learn
to love your voice because you
have a very nice voice.
And a low female voice
is very, very nice.
Don't try to monkey with
what nature has given you
to the extent that you ruin
something that's natural.
You have a naturally low voice.
I would enjoy it and just
try to-- I would encourage
you to build your
voice at this level.
And you'll see, your
range will increase.
But in terms of raising
your speaking voice,
I don't recommend
that you do that.
AUDIENCE: But I sing
with a very high pitch.
I can sing high
pitch [INAUDIBLE].
GARY CATONA: I'd have
to hear your singing
to make a thorough
judgment about that.
MALE SPEAKER: I think studies
have shown, though, too,
that the deeper your voice,
the more authoritative,
whether you're in a meeting
or doing a newscast.
GARY CATONA: Of course.
The voice is a highly
psychological aspect
of who we are.
It gives us power.
AUDIENCE: How to project better,
make one's voice lower, slower,
and cut out ums.
GARY CATONA: Again, singing,
your vocal mechanism is,
think of it like a muscle.
You have to improve the
ability of your vocal muscle
to create vowel sounds.
If I go [SINGING] hee,
you're hearing an E vowel.
You're hearing my throat
making that sound.
You have to develop
that capability.
Speaking is basically that.
It's flexing muscles.
So by using the proper
voice building exercises,
you develop the ability to flex
your muscles more efficiently
and more effectively, and
you produce more voice.
So volume in voice is greater
pressure below the vocal folds.
When you speak or sing,
the cords come together,
and the breath that
normally flies through
is stopped to some extent.
And that pressure is the
source of your voice.
The greater the pressure,
the more voice you have.
So by building
the vocal muscles,
to vocal cords come
together more strongly,
which prevents more
breath from escaping,
which increases the
sound of your voice.
AUDIENCE: Would you
be willing to walk us
through one of your
beginner exercises?
GARY CATONA: Sure.
Here we go.
Watch what I do.
I want everybody to find
this part of the voice.
Watch.
Do this, everybody.
Go, uh.
AUDIENCE: Uh.
GARY CATONA: But the full voice.
AUDIENCE: Uh!
GARY CATONA: That's it.
Now notice where that's
coming from, from the back.
Now watch how I
do this exercise.
[SINGING IN RISING
AND DESCENDING PITCH]
Notice the larynx was down.
If you focus on my mouth, you'll
notice where my tongue is.
Watch one more time.
[SINGING IN RISING
AND DESCENDING PITCH]
Now, I want the
men to do it first.
All the men, do it with me.
Ready?
Go, uh.
AUDIENCE: Uh.
GARY CATONA: Here we go.
[SINGING]
GARY CATONA: Smile.
Louder.
Back.
You are inaugurated into
the voice building club.
Girls, same thing, only you have
to do it a little higher, up
here.
[SINGING]
Girls, uh.
AUDIENCE: Uh.
GARY CATONA: Here we go.
[SINGING]
Let's hear it.
Back down.
Now what does that
do, that exercise?
Lowers the larynx,
stretches the muscles,
and it keeps the
voice in the back
of the throat where it belongs.
AUDIENCE: Notice
that I just stood up.
I naturally do this because
I'm writing a novel,
and I do open mic greetings.
And I'm told I do
a good job at it,
and I've been urged to
do podcasting, which
is a good idea for
budding authors.
And when I read, I
also naturally slip
into different character voices.
I can't help myself.
That's what I naturally do.
Except for my
superheroine character.
I read that in my regular voice.
Could you tell me
the name of your app,
and do you have
any specific advice
for people tend to naturally do
different character voices when
they read?
GARY CATONA: The app is
called Voice Builder.
It's an iPhone, iPod app
Again, what you--
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Android app.
GARY CATONA: That's the plan.
Again, you're a gymnast.
Do you understand
what I'm saying?
That's what you are.
So if you do the app, you'll
find that your characters will
be much more believable
because, again,
all you're doing is
manipulating your vocal muscles
in a specific way.
And that's what-- you'll be able
to do that with more efficiency
by building your voice.
MALE SPEAKER: And Gary
and I have already
discussed making an
Android version of this app
to reach even more people
throughout the world.
So he's already working on that.
GARY CATONA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: At the
beginning, you described
that most people focus
on the diaphragm,
and that you focus
on the vocal cords.
Do you completely
de-emphasize the diagram?
Or what's the relationship
between those two
muscles in your mind?
GARY CATONA: I will shock
you by telling you something.
All of you have heard
this expression,
sing from the diaphragm.
Right?
Do you know it's physically
impossible to do that?
When you sing, when
you take a breath,
the diaphragm drops, and
air fills up your lungs.
When you breathe out,
which is when you sing,
the diaphragm is disconnected,
completely disengaged.
It cannot be used,
even if you wanted to.
So again, one of the
confusing concepts in voice
is this concept of singing
from the diaphragm.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
it's definitely
challenging conventional wisdom.
GARY CATONA: So there
are so many myths
that populate the
field of voice.
It's shocking.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
not a singer, but I
used to be a wind musician, and
I can also talk fairly loud.
And I've noticed
over the years, it
seems like there's definitely
a different range of volume
that people either
have or can develop.
And I've always felt
like people talk
about the difference
between being loud and being
able to project.
But I've never known if
there was anything really
there to that, except
I've noticed it in people.
And I was wondering if
you could say something
about that, either from
the science about it
or what you think about that.
GARY CATONA: Yes.
There's certain frequencies
that travel better
than other frequencies.
For example, in an orchestra,
the piccolo really travels.
You have to tell
the piccolo player
to hold back so he
doesn't overtake.
And it's a thin sound,
but the frequency carries.
In singing, you have
certain kind of frequencies.
There's a frequency called the
singer's format, for example.
It's that part of the voice
that if I go [SINGING] hee,
hee-- hear that buzz
sound in the voice?
That's part of the singer's
format, which penetrates.
You can have a sound that's big
but doesn't have the singer's
format, which doesn't carry
as much as a voice that's
smaller but with that frequency.
So it's the frequency
we're talking about.
AUDIENCE: I wonder
about that a little bit
because, like I said, when
I was a wind musician,
and I could play a
note on something,
but I know a pro, like--
I was a saxophone player.
So I could play
something, and Stan Getz
was able to be 10 times
louder than I was.
GARY CATONA: He found the
frequency that traveled.
That was part of his skill.
You know what I'm talking about?
That's what he did.
He was able to find
those frequencies that
seared through everything else.
AUDIENCE: I sort of
have two questions.
One was a follow-on
to what you just
said about not singing
from the diaphragm.
Yet there has to be
pressurization because clearly,
the difference between a
quiet voice and a loud voice
has to do with the pressure
behind the column of air.
So how do you describe that if
not singing from the diaphragm?
GARY CATONA: First of all,
you sing from the throat
because that's where
the vocal cords are.
That's the first part.
The cords are not
located in your stomach.
They're located in your throat.
Secondly, breath is
crucial to singing.
But what controls the breath
are the vocal cords, not
the other way around.
When you speak, the
vocal folds close,
and the breath is blocked.
And the way the
vocal cords behave
determines how the
breath is maneuvered.
We have it in
reverse, mistakenly.
We have the breath
controlling the vocal cords,
which doesn't work that way.
And I noticed this when
I began teaching people
with vocal problems.
Many of them would
have no breath.
They'd speak, and often,
their breath would leave.
And you'd say, well, the
problem with the person
is a breathing problem.
By stretching the vocal folds,
all the sudden, not only
does the breath come back,
but the voice comes back.
So by making the vocal cords
stronger and more coordinated,
it literally causes
the voice to be
produced in a more
efficient way.
So the emphasis
is on the throat.
That controls the breath,
not the other way around.
AUDIENCE: And the
other thing is,
you were talking earlier
about vocal strain.
And I was wondering if
you could talk at all
about the transitions of
chest voice and head voice.
GARY CATONA: Yeah, one of the
important concepts in singing
is moving from one
register to the next.
And it's been the
bone of contention
for a long, long time.
And there are various
exercises that
purport to be able to
show this transition.
For example, if I go
[SINGING IN RISING PITCH],
that transition into
that part of the voice,
how do you get there?
You get there by using certain
vowel sounds that guide you
into making those
kind of transitions.
You see what I'm saying?
So it's knowing how
to create the vowel
sounds in the throat that will
guide you into other registers.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, thank you,
everybody in the audience.
I did want to ask
one final question.
And that is, there
was an article
in "Time" magazine that singing
actually changes the brain.
And so I want you to tell us
a little bit more about that,
but I want to know if
the converse is true.
And that is, does having
someone sing off key change
the listener's brain?
GARY CATONA: It can change
this listener's brain.
I'll tell you that right now.
Of course.
First of all, there are certain
theories about why do we sing.
And some people argue that it
has an evolutionary purpose.
For example, when you
sing, what happens?
You're together
with other people.
You're communing
And you're sharing an
intimate part of who you are.
At the same time, you're
retaining your individuality.
Think about that one.
That's why the vision of
making the whole world sing
is such a beautiful
idea, because it
does two things at once.
It brings people together, but
it allows for individuality
at the same time.
So they know, also, that
singing causes certain hormones
to be released into the brain.
And it may have an
evolutionary experience.
But what I can tell you is that
it's a beautiful experience.
MALE SPEAKER: Fantastic.
So I want to thank Gary.
I encourage everyone to
check out his Voice Building
app, also his book,
"Revolution in Singing."
Personally, I want
to thank you and what
you've done for my son.
It's just amazing to hear
more about this subject
and to dispel
preconceived notions
and debunk myths
that have perpetuated
through time about
singing and the voice.
So we greatly appreciate that.
Greatly appreciate everybody in
the audience, our tech support.
And on behalf of the
Google Talk series,
thank you very much
for coming over today.
GARY CATONA: Thank
you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]